Let's get right into audience questions today,
last set of audience questions before our little
vacation and then we'll be back and we'll
take more of them. Cancel culture. Got a
very interesting question. We know that, David,
that the right hates council culture, supposedly,
but how do they believe it should be fixed anyway?
Isn't any, quote, solution authoritarian by date?
By definition? This is a great point. Essentially,
all answers for how the right wants to
fix the problem of council culture are extremely
authoritarian, other than just like culture
changing, where people don't say when they don't
like something anymore, which I don't know how
you achieve. I don't know how you would ban Cancio
culture or the fact that actions have consequences
in terms of sometimes people will tweet about
it. Sometimes people will tell a business,
I'm not going to buy your product because of this
or that or the other thing that you as a company
said or one of your employee said or whatever,
any of those actions would be authoritarian and
they would be against what they claim their
views to be. Remember, the right says they're
about free speech and people getting to say what
they want and businesses not being regulated.
Any way that you try to fix what they define
as council culture would either require
limiting businesses, regulating businesses
somehow so they can't act on whatever information
they want, assuming it's not illegal, like
someone's race or religion, to say we don't
want to work with you anymore, you're fired or
whatever. That's very heavy handed authoritarian
business regulation, which the right claims to
be against, saying people don't have the right
to tweet their displeasure at what a celebrity
or a business said. They don't have the right to
announce and carry out a boycott on a business
because that's what they want to do. It's all
insanely authoritarian. There would be no
conceivable legislative solution to quote, council
culture that wouldn't. Violate or in some other
ways, violate the First Amendment or limit speech.
So what you have to do once you understand there's
no legislative way to deal with council culture,
you have to realize that the continued demands
from the right to deal with council culture either
go against the very First Amendment they claim
to defend or are merely pandering. And that's
one of the most important things, I think, that
we can take away from this discussion, which is
that many of these right wingers and some on the
left who are talking about council culture, not
as something that happens infrequently and that we
should really and think about and evaluate and say
what what makes sense when they are talking about
it, they don't even really want a solution in the
sense that they know there isn't going to be one.
This is just a cultural reality. Elections rather
I'm sorry, speech. Elections do have consequences.
Speech has consequences. And those consequences
in most cases are also protected by the First
Amendment as far as the government is involved
by business freedom when businesses are involved,
etc.. Now, we can't ignore the huge hypocrisy from
the right on this issue. Who are the two biggest
victims of cancelation that you can think of
over the last 20 years from either clear it's
the Dixie Chicks who were a are a country music
band. But when they came out against George W.
Bush's foreign policy, the right, which is very
intertwined with country music, canceled them.
They were blacklisted from so many radio stations
and the right said Dixie Chicks are over Colin
Kaepernick. These two biggest instances of these
cancelations that the right claims to be against
were done by the right. And then you had people
throwing Curis out the window. Starbucks was bad.
The NFL for the kneeling Amazon for saying we're
not going to host parler. You know, Taylor Swift,
when she came out and took political positions,
the right loves to cancel people using
their terminology, but they claim to be
against it. And so this entire thing is
a ruse. Now, as I talked about last week
during during our interview
with with Professor Kovalik.
Just because we can identify some instances where
someone was wrongly shamed or fired doesn't mean
we call this an epidemic, and he actually agreed
with me on that issue. And you bring me a wrong
decision that was made. And if it was indeed made
wrongly, I'll be right there with you. It's no no
problem whatsoever. But we can't allow these right
wingers to claim they're against council culture
when there are some of the biggest councilors.
Look at what Republicans did to Cindy McCain.
Cindy McCain, the widow of the late Senator John
McCain, was censured because she didn't want to
vote for Trump. She wasn't voting for Trump.
They are a complete and total hypocrites. And
this is really getting to the key thing, which
is any solution that they would propose would
be extraordinarily authoritarian and arguably
against the First Amendment. And many of them
don't really want solutions. They just want
to pander. And unfortunately, it's working
very well. They're getting a lot of mileage
out of this Dr. Seuss cancel culture stuff.